Britney Spears went to court today
taking action against her ex-manager Sam
Lutfi now it was another member of
Britney's family who showed up jamie has
Britney doing any comment on the Sam
left you were skinnier please damn it
that was Brittany's dad Jamie today
outside of court just moments after she
was granted a temporary restraining
order Brittany's team claims Lutfi
started a new campaign of harassment
shortly after she checked into a mental
health facility Britney's lawyers
claimed the harassment has threatened
her safety and caused severe mental
trauma among the allegations are that
Lutfi sent threatening texts to her
family posted threatening comments about
Brittany on social media and threatened
to release trunks of damaging materials
which he allegedly accumulated during
the time he was her manager Fredi looked
great but b was a constant presence in
Brittany's life during her darkest years
between 2007 and 2008 in 2008 Brittany
was committed to a psych ward and placed
on an involuntary hole her mom Lynn
toady teeth the family had been cut off
we wouldn't really communicate she she
kind of really shut me out he shut us
all out that's when Brittany's dad Jamie
was granted a conservatorship of her
affairs and a drastic turn around occur
my main thing is to enjoy life and take
one day at a time
Lutfi denies the claims and his attorney
told ET the restraining order is
unnecessary we're disappointed in the
results we think it's overly broad and
violates mr. Levy's constitutional
rights
[Music]
[Applause]